[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اولا عندما ابدا الحديث عن اوكرانيا فانني
اتحدث بصوره اساسيه كقائد متقاعد للقوات
الجويه وليس كموظف لدى بي اي سيستمز لكنني
اعتقد ان الصراع في اوكرانيا قد اخذ
الكثيرين على حين غره وما كان يجب ان ينشب
هذا الصراع اصلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فنحن نتحدث عن بلدين دخل في اتوني صراع
ولديهما قدرات متوازنه الى حد كبير من
نواحي العده لاننا اعتدنا على عمليات يكون
فيها لاحد الطرفين المتنازعين اليد الطول
في الحرب انجز التعبير وتجد ان احدهما لن
يصعب عليه تحقيق مكاسب ومن ثم الحفاظ على
الاستقلاليه
[موسيقى]
امم لكن الصوره مختلفه في اوكرانيا واكله
طرفين يتحارب بضراوه من اجل الحصول على
ميزه التفوق سواء كان ذلك بصوره مؤقته ام
التفوق الجغرافي بحيث يكون لديهم خيار
انتقاء مناطق عملياتهم وهذا ليس امرا
مفاجئا وهذا ما يحدث عند الصراع بين
الاقرار
[موسيقى]